wir schauen jetzt zur nordsee hier
startet auf der unbewohnten
vogelschutzinsel im minsener oog eine
müllsammelaktion und mein kollege markus
siebler ist für uns vor ort markus was
ist das denn für eine müllsammelaktion
die da jetzt gleich stattfindet ja diese
müll sammelaktion findet jetzt bereits
seit einigen jahren stadt bereits heute
in der früh sind über 20 segelboote
aufgebrochen
zur insel in seenot das ist eine
ungewohnte vogelschutzinsel die man
normalerweise gar nicht betreten darf
und die insel liegt hier in
niedersachsen niedersächsischen
wattenmeer und da wir natürlich immer
nordwestwind lagen haben wird hier
relativ viel müll angeschwemmt und da
die insel eben nicht bewohntes gibt es
auch keine menschen die den beseitigen
und deshalb hat der verein salt war tv
bereits seit einigen jahren dazu
aufgerufen diesen müll zu sammeln es
sind etwa 70 menschen hier heute auf der
insel die den strand und die dünen nach
müll absoluten und bei mir steht jetzt
gerdts schiffler der initiator dieser
aktion ehrt was sind deine erfahrung
über die letzten jahre was habt ihr so
gesammelt also wir sammeln hier alles
was das meer so frei gibt das sind
natürlich in erster linie fischerei
abfälle die netze sind
haushaltsgegenstände da ist die
berufsschifffahrt die hier meinetwegen
ihren müll irgendwo ablädt und der die
strömungsgünstige insel die ist also so
gelagert dass ihn auffängt und hier auf
dieser vogelinsel ist es also so dass
gerade die vögel die jungvögel sich in
diesen netzen verheddern und dann daran
kopien alles andere was wir nicht
sammeln kriegt das meer vielleicht
wieder und kommt dann irgendwann in die
nahrungskette und landet irgendwann beim
menschen
das heißt also wir schützen hier aktiv
die seevögel und die meeresbewohner
wir können uns ja mal heute anschauen
was bereits gesammelt wurde am heutigen
tag ihr seid ja etwa eine stunde schon
in aktion zeig mal was ist heute schon
zusammen das übliche also ganz klar
berufsschifffahrt in erster linie die
fischer dann haben wir sachen die die
bade eine dinge für kinder wir haben
natürlich haushaltsmüll alle die hier
fliegt natürlich kommt natürlich auch
mal glas an alles mögliche wie man hier
sieht
in jeglicher art das ist natürlich im
besonderen gefährlich da können also
chemikalien aus drin sein
die also wirklich eine große große
gefährdung darstellen kann man irgendwas
zur menge sagen wie viel glück haben
beispielsweise letztes jahr zusammen
beide aktien also im letzten jahr haben
wir von diesen big packs 12 gesammelt 12
und ich denke mal so vom gewicht her
sind das sieben bis acht tonnen wir
haben in den besten jahren die wir
hatten haben wir zehn tonnen müll
gesammelt
also ich denke mal dass so mit 70 leuten
mit 70 freiwilligen das ist schon eine
große leistung letzte frage wie geht es
heute noch weiter also wie lange sucht
ihr und was passiert dann
ja das zeitfenster ist natürlich nicht
so groß weil wir natürlich nur über die
apple
das heißt wir die landen hier an und
kommen also mit ablaufendem wasser hier
an
dann gehen wir auf die insel und mit
auflaufendem wasser irgendwann müssen
wir die insel wieder verlassen wir haben
zeitfenster von maximal sechs sieben
stunden ja so viel hier von der insel
minsener oog wie man sieht wie gesagt
sind mehrere menschen hier auf der
ganzen insel verteilt und fleißig noch
an müll sammeln das wird wahrscheinlich
noch bis zum späten nachmittag dauern
mehr nachrichten und bikinis nur weil
bild schau dir hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren